Jason what do you asked most often about
in terms of film distribution and what's
your answer you know the question I'm
asked most often about film distribution
is is this the right way to distribute
my movie I talked to a lot of filmmakers
that are looking for distribution
they're looking for ways to get their
moving in the marketplace and they're
coming to me after having several
conversations with several different
distributors and sales agents and I've
been there as well so I understand those
conversations initially especially a
first-time filmmaker somebody calls you
they promise you the world and when you
finally see the agreement you're like
this doesn't really I mean where is all
the stuff we talked about of the phone
call it's not here in the agreement and
then you get a lot of other filmmakers
where especially these days where
everything's becoming video on-demand so
you have a lot of aggregators that say
I'm gonna get you on the iTunes or
Amazon or some of the other marketplaces
out there and you're saying like five
people told me they can get me onto this
platform who should I go with and the
reason you're asking that question is
because and I'm going to say something
that I think a lot of film distributors
you know kind of understand and it got
level but might be afraid to say out
loud so I'll say it film distribution
has become a commodity it has become
this thing that a lot of people can do
it's become this thing that if you want
to get on some of those popular
platforms do you can do it and you don't
have to sign away all of your rights if
you just do some research you'll figure
out that there's several companies out
there that for example if you wanted to
get on iTunes they'll do they'll take
you right on the iTunes they won't take
anything off the back end you just pay a
fee up front and what that fee is
covering for the most part is the
encoding process the very rigorous
encoding and delivery process that's
necessary to get your movie from point A
to point B
you